dernier budget du ministre girard
présenté avant les élections on a
l'impression que le gouvernement se
garde quelques munitions pour la
campagne électorale pas de baisses de
taxes potes de baisses d'impôts
annoncées aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement le gommer un montant de 500
$ qui sera remis dans votre déclaration
de revenus 2021 si vous gagnez 100 mille
dollars ou moins 100000 dollars au moins
les citoyens au québec auront droit 1
500 $ pour compenser la hausse de
l'inflation l'inflation la hausse du
coût de la vie faut comprendre nous tout
de même qu'une personne qui gagne 20
mille ou une personne qui gagne 100
mille aura le même 500 $ et pour un
couple qui gagne par exemple 100 1000
chacun 200 milles au total safran mille
dollars de revenus du gouvernement et je
vous mentionne également que on parle du
revenu net donc si vous avez fait 110
milles émis 15 dollars en réserves votre
revenu net et de 95000 vous avez droit
aux 500 dollars y a rien sur les tarifs
d'électricité qui vont augmenter
sensiblement cette année on verra dans
le prochain budget déficit de 6
milliards 500 millions mais y'a une
provision de 2 milliards et demi et
encore deux milliards et demi pour la
coved 19 dans ce budget il ya de
l'argent pour le fonds des générations
donc dans les faits le gouvernement est
essentiellement déjà d' équilibre
budgétaire on met beaucoup d'argent dans
la refondation du système de santé
l'éducation l'enseignement supérieur la
productivité également des entreprises
mais la croissance économique à partir
de 2024 sera quand même assez faible en
un an et demi pour cent au québec donc
ça va prendre un petit peu plus de
productivité encore 140 2 milliards dans
les infrastructures mais beaucoup
d'argent pour les routes et pour le
transport collectif mais l'argent pour
les routes est encore plus important que
pour le transport collectif et une
baisse du rabais si vous achetez un
véhicule électrique qui passe de 8000 à
7000 $ pour un véhicule électrique et de
4000 à 3500 $ pour un véhicule
électrique d'occasions voilà c'était le
budget on se reverra durant la campagne
électorale pour d'autres promesses
peut-être des baisses d'impôts